yo bootleg care podcast special guest
about to do this thing my guy tf is here
deleon welcome man what's good welcome
welcome welcome um so uh for people who
don't know who you are man where are you
from
i'm from south central i'm from the 50s
grew up uh yeah i'm hey i'm south
central bound you've been super active
just dropping i mean your catalog is
pretty extensive um
how long have you like like i guess how
long have you been
officially kind of focused on the
rapping because i'm sure you've been
rapping a long time but like where all
your focus was on this [ __ ] officially
uh [ __ ] when i as soon as i came home i
was like 2012 i got straight to it but
like i was still like in and out in and
out you feel me playing both sides of
the thing
you know i was still on [ __ ] you
know uh but like officially was
[ __ ] like probably 2014 15. so since
then you just been locked in yeah yeah
yeah that's that's when i really like
like really like
pushed it in like you feel me like i'm
like all right well that's what i'm
doing
that's what i'm doing feel me and then
like boom after that that's when uh
i ended up doing the tooky nose record
with q
and then after that like i even had no
choice no more
yeah once you do a record with someone
like you especially for real what year
was that i was 2016. yeah that's when
[ __ ] is yeah so from 16 to to so here
for like lit for real for real maybe
like the past seven years that had to be
like uh was that like a
pivotal moment for you where you were
like okay this is hell yeah this is the
push i needed i was signing autographs
on titties and [ __ ] my family so yeah
that's always nice that's perfect good
titties are like sometimes you know the
girls who will let you sign their
titties usually th they're flapjacks you
know what i mean
points they were good
joints yeah um
how long were you like well you said you
were in and out a lot but like what's
the longest bid you ended up doing uh
five years five years
and that's when you got out in 20 was it
2012 yeah 2012. [ __ ] if you don't mind
me asking what what would you end up
going in for just trying to find some
money i mean damn you know going to get
some money you know so
that's how i'd be
i feel like a lot of that's happening in
la right now we were just talking about
that
yeah no it is
i mean uh
yeah like it's it's been it's that's a
that's nothing new but it's just do you
think it's just like broadcasters
it's social media we see it on when we
you know and and p like the younger
dudes now they like oh yeah like they go
tell you i just did it yeah you know
like they go do something and then go
straight to the internet and be like
yeah i just did it actually it's crazy
to me it still boggles my mind how
people
can't like
wait do i do i need these yeah when we
were about to rap so yeah you're going
to need them yeah
not just the whole the whole self
snitching thing is crazy it's like yeah
no that's crazy people have such an ego
where they just can't help themselves
but
not for real but to tell you about what
the [ __ ] they got going on man um you
were just telling me you were in the
studio last night at q spot working on
finishing your new album yeah you
already have it out in the drop this
year
yeah uh blame kansas you know produced
by uh me [ __ ] and rock marciano
uh
yeah playing kansas that's that's that's
one of my that's one of my uh
that's one of my illest
records
you know to date because uh you know
just based on like the meaning of it the
the backstory of kansas the street right
like that's where i grew up at that's
where
you know i really wouldn't even be who i
am without that street
you know so uh
you know that whole the whole factor in
on on everything about that street like
for me to be able to you know to come
back and
and and
and do it like that
with that meaning you know that's that's
kind of dumb uh before we have you do
your thing you're super tapped in with a
lot of east coast dudes
rock marciano just don't be working with
just anybody you know what i'm saying
he's very selective he's a great anr
he's a great producer he's a great
rapper i mean
um
even like working with conway or
you know all these guys how did you end
up linking up with the east coast [ __ ]
because i feel like you you're pretty
tapped in when it comes to just kind of
that whole side much more than a lot of
other you know contemporaries of yours
in la
uh
uh i met
i met uh
i'm at the whole grazelda camp like
probably 2018.
at a uh
some type of we was doing a
like a festival in atlanta
it was 83c probably it was yeah it was
uh we went out there and we tapped in
with them and then from there
uh
i came uh they came out here they had a
show out here and uh
we went to the show
uh wait wait hold on let me rewind
remember why number one so before i even
went to atlanta i had a session with
alchemist
okay so we had a session where i had a
social alchemist and uh he bring up he's
like yeah man
this was like maybe
right before or after coachella okay
around that time so he was like yeah man
uh
and he was just talking about he was
talking about him i'm like what the [ __ ]
are these dudes he talking about right i
didn't know at the time
so
i ended up running into him at
uh in atlanta
so from there
they already knew who i was based
on uh
my boy doe i guess he knew he knew
somebody in the camp and all that he had
ties to somebody in here
or over there and uh
and he played them some of my [ __ ] and
they were like oh [ __ ] this thing kind
of dope
you know but at the time that's when i
just dropped
no hooks mm-hmm the first one you know
no hooks that's uh just straight rap
just straight rap rap like bars bars you
know uh
and uh
he showed him that and they was like
damn bring bring him to the you know
let's see what's up like you know let's
chop it up let's see who he is you know
it's from there we've been like they've
been like i've been [ __ ] with them so
when they came out here they got out
here
uh i went to the show
and uh i met flea
i met fleet and then from there
you know uh me and him we just we just
took a liking to each other and i was
like [ __ ] i [ __ ] with dude for sure and
then uh from there we
it was just
you know so
my my tapping is with with the east
coast has been like
from
even when when i was on tour with q
mm-hmm like we went to new york and i
just
[ __ ] i was [ __ ] running around the
whole city like i tapped in with the
streets
tapped in with the streets like i'm like
man i ain't trying to go see no
i'm not trying to do times square and
then right right right right okay
you know take me where it's scandalous
yeah feel me so
from there i just been you know i've
been
i [ __ ] the east coast heavy um
you uh you were saying you didn't talk
about the new album so the new item's
coming hopefully soon right you're
almost live new album is uh
set for june 1st uh uh scanlan summer
too and i got another project with 211
scanlan summer three 211 is here yeah
deleon
[Music]
shout out my guy 211 man he's gonna be
back on the show soon
we're gonna run it back yeah but uh we
got we got we just dropped scandalous
levels too
what like
a month ago
like a month ago so soon it's crazy the
same day we dropped that project we was
in the studio recording
the new one three three that's it's
crazy yeah so non-stop man
non-stop
[ __ ] you're trying my bars let's get to
some bars man
[Music]
all right
let's get it
[Music]
ellie on
yes
[Music]
okay
okay
bulletproof wallet i'm on the third
track while a [ __ ] getting knowledge
from a vactec look rook attack fat split
splash leave your [ __ ] wet then licks be
50 50. i'm blowing cash off a mishap
perhaps
[ __ ] around and blow up shooting crap
fast money i'm going forever running
back we gon run it up [ __ ] the summer up
yeah we come from nothing if you ain't
solid i don't [ __ ] with [ __ ] shout out
uncle ruckers pick the wrists ain't not
a stone on it but shout out to the
jungles i'm in the lab the bottle gone
shout out to the runners columbiana fit
my best description or as pocahontas
i'll ever bring some sand to the beach
we don't go bahamas i ain't never held
no grubs let's put that [ __ ] behind us
[ __ ] acting like they hoes i call them
baby mamas lately i've been reaping off
the benefits of paying homage
hurricane scanlan ain't no way around it
it's the type of [ __ ] that's gonna make
stevie wonder see about it the whip got
stevie wonderton [ __ ] can't even see
your body now you throwing tensions
about the [ __ ] i don't see the problem
all she did was take me sliding murdered
saying gabbana kamikaze lower mark [ __ ]
with us that suicide we got the streets
from coast to coast the mexicans and the
other sides and we got the caucasians
big year any occasion but when it come
to green i get racist [ __ ] you pay me
i'm on the edge ain't nobody can save me
off my lawyer fees alone i could have
bought three mercedes off the line fully
loaded my interior gravy i'd have been
through hell and back i ain't tripping
i'm gravy how these [ __ ] fresh off
demon time and kissing their babies
[Music]
they're fresh off demon time kissing
their babies
and dirty ass everything's skeletons man
you feel me
my god deleon there it is hey i know you
just watched a brand new freestyle
presented to you by our good folks at
lrg don't forget if you go to lrg right
now the website will be right there
broom l dash r dash g.com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
get thirty percent off your order that's
l dash r dash g dot com you'll see it
right down there
save 30 off your order by putting in
that promo code bootleg and shout out to
lrg we got another freestyle coming next
week